- Hi, it's Rie.
Today I've been challenged
to take a popular food
and "Make it Fancy."
As a reminder, if you want
to check out our merch,
go to shopmakeitfancy.com.
Today's challenger is Katie.
- Hey Rie,
I am so excited to be
challenging you on this episode
of "Make it Fancy."
It's been awhile.
I also have become a recent member
of a very cool adult club, Costco!
I want you to make a Costco
rotisserie chicken fancy.
I know you're gonna do
something wild and awesome,
and it's probably gonna involve booze,
so can't wait to see it.
- Costco rotisserie chicken.
I've never had this before.
And also I've never been to Costco.
Oh, it's heavy, hefty.
It smells good.
It looks great.
It's nice brown color.
- [Producer] How much
do you think this costs?
- 12.99.
- [Producer] $4.99.
- The whole chicken?
Do they have their own farm?
So there is not a lot of
artificial ingredients.
This is already fancy
despite of the price.
I think this is the fanciest ingredients
I've ever challenged.
Mm, well seasoned.
It's tender, it's a little bit dry.
It's very tasty.
Seasoning is very simple.
I want to make something creative upgrade,
not a transformation for this time.
This is a great challenge and as always,
I'm excited to "Make it Fancy."
(cheerful music)
All right, here's what I got.
Carrots, parsley, thyme,
heavy cream, oyster
mushroom, shiitake mushroom,
king trumpet mushroom, onions,
potatoes, garlic, chives, butter,
pearl onions, and pancetta.
From the pantry, I got
flour, red wine, and brandy.
Double alcohol.
All right, let's get started.
(chicken sliding)
"Make it Fancy."
(waltz music)
We have whole chicken and I use gloves.
- [Producer] So when these come out,
you have to grab them so fast
'cause so many people want them.
And the boxes are so hot.
- So you cannot hold it.
That kind of gives me anxiety too.
I'm not sure if I want to fight that.
So I'm going to cut up chicken.
Chicken has joint and you put your knife,
it kind of separates by itself.
You have to cut through joints, not bone.
This is thigh and leg.
Sharp knife is important
when you are cutting
'cause if it's dull,
you cannot do a nice clean cut,
especially the skin.
The wing.
Gonna use use it for later.
And breast you also kind of see the line,
so go kind of follow that line.
Here's your breast.
I think if you know chicken
anatomy, it's easier too.
Breast.
Oh, I saw the wishbone.
I'm going to use meat and
carcass in two different ways.
Adding carcass in the Instant Pot.
I think this is also
like Instant Pot season.
One onion cut in quarter.
Three sprigs of thyme.
Adding three cups of water.
Put the lid.
It's always confusing.
(Rie laughing)
It's obvious I don't have it a home.
Use pressure cook mode
and cook for 45 minutes.
If you don't have Instant Pot at home,
you can just use regular pot, bring it.
(Instant Pot beeping)
Bring it to a boil and
cook for 20 minutes.
I also want to use the leftover juice.
Save this for later.
45 minutes later.
We waited a little bit so
the steam naturally released.
Open this and strain
the chicken stock out.
The rotisserie chicken already seasoned
so I think it will be great for later.
I have Dutch oven and I'm
heating medium-low heat.
Cook pancetta.
I have six ounce.
I'm going to render the fat and
you want to do low and slow.
I was advised by a few people
I should get Costco membership
because diapers are great deal.
Mainly diapers.
Also one of my friends told
me gas is great deal as well.
My family is small family.
I don't buy a lot of bulk things
and if you get 34 bathroom tissue,
where do you store?
So you want to cook pancetta
low-medium heat or low heat
so you can render out those fat.
If you cook high heat,
you get nice caramelized
and fat doesn't render.
Also when you're cooking bacon,
you want to start with
cold pan or a low heat.
It's the same reason you
want to render those fat out.
Oh, I saw someone recently
tagged me on the Instagram.
This person made candy corn macaron
and Fruit Loop cream puffs.
- [Producer] Oh, they're doing everything.
- Just two.
I think this one is easy
enough to make at home,
so when you make anything
from "Make it Fancy,"
tell me on the Instagram.
My account is @thedessertsnob.
Pancetta is nice and crisped up.
Transfer to paper towel lined plate,
add one diced onion and two carrots.
I have mixed mushroom total eight ounces.
I'm just using half and I'm going
to use remaining mushroom for later.
Cook until soften.
Raise the heat to medium-high heat
and saute until all the ingredients
are soft and begin to caramelize.
- [Producer] Rie, what is the
origin of your Instagram name?
- I like dessert and when I was looking
for dessert snob was taken,
so I just put the dessert snob.
I don't know, snob is not a great word.
So maybe I should change it.
All right, it looks good so I'm going
to add finely chopped garlic
and cook until fragrant.
Add in two tablespoons
of tomato paste, stir in.
Add in one tablespoon of flour,
cook one to two minutes
so it doesn't have a like floury flavor.
Now I'm adding about three
tablespoon of brandy.
Deglaze bottom of the pan
where flavor is stuck.
Two cups of red wine.
I'm going to just go in.
(wine splashing)
Bring this to a simmer.
Add in one cup of chicken
stock I made earlier.
Bay leaf and thyme.
Bring this to simmer
and reduce this by half
or about 15 to 20 minutes.
Sauce, it's reduced.
Very nice smell.
I wish you guys can smell.
Add the chicken I cut earlier.
I feel like the breast
is a little too big,
so I'm going to cut in half.
Put the lid on top and
cook for 20 minutes.
I'm heating up frying
pan over medium heat.
Melt one tablespoon of butter
and add in two tablespoon of olive oil,
and heat up until butter
is completely melted.
Add in eight ounces of frozen pearl onion.
Cook until those are caramelized.
Pearl onion is caramelized
and I'm going to add rest of the mushroom.
Season with salt.
Veggies are done but we
have more things to do.
Pour plenty of water.
I'm adding two cup potatoes.
Bring it to a boil and cook
this potato until tender.
So when you're cooking potato,
you want to make sure to
start with cold water,
because if you start
cooking with hot water,
outside it's cooked but
inside it doesn't cook.
Potato is cooked through and
I'm going to strain water.
You can just strain in a sink like this,
but this sink is fake so I'm
using strainer on the table.
This is not how you do it usually.
You put this in a glass bowl.
Set aside until I use it.
Heating up one cup of cream
and 10 tablespoons of butter.
Reserve the chicken fat and juice
from the Costco rotisserie chicken.
Eight cloves of smashed garlic.
Bring this to simmer.
The cream is come to simmer.
I'm going to strain this
and I'm adding cream
mixture little by little
and smash potato.
Add a little more.
I'm going to season with salt and pepper.
The chicken fat flavor
definitely comes through.
The mashed potatoes taste
good and let's move on.
Since Katie is coming,
I'm going to plate for her and for myself.
You want to do one white
meat and one dark meat.
So chicken breast here, chicken leg.
Add this delicious sauce.
Add rest of the chicken in here.
At home you can put cooked pearl onions
and mushroom in the sauce,
but I think it's so pretty so I'm going
to just garnish afterwards.
I also have pancetta and I'm going
to use these for big plate.
Sprinkle some chives on the mashed potato.
Pepper.
Parsley.
And we are done.
(uplifting music)
Costco rotisserie chicken coq au vin.
Delicious.
(cheerful music)
Welcome back, Katie.
- Hi, Rie!
(Rie laughing)
- Are you Katie?
- Yeah.
(Katie laughing)
Are you horrified?
It's really scary.
- If you wanna take it off?
- Yeah, I do, I do.
(both laughing)
- It has tail and everything.
- It does have a tail.
- I heard you recently
got a Costco membership?
- Yes I did.
I was very excited.
- Is it worth it?
- It is, absolutely.
I was like, I don't need
this much like toilet paper,
but you do.
Like, it's just one trip.
- For you?
(both laughing)
- I have really enjoyed
my Costco membership.
You need to know exactly what
you're going in there for
or you're going to come out with like a,
like a watch, and like a patio chair set.
- So I made a Costco
rotisserie chicken coq au vin.
- I don't do anything this fancy.
I just put some on the plate.
Mm, so much flavor.
- I think this is very rustic French dish.
- But it looks fancy.
- It has brandy and it has red wine.
- Ooh, I knew you were going
to do something with booze.
- Double alcohol.
- You definitely made it fancy.
- Thank you.
- Is it easy to upgrade like this
or did this take a little bit time?
- No, this is super easy.
So like anyone can make at home.
We have one more thing to do.
- What?
- Oh, oh.
- You.
Three, two, one.
- [Both] "Make it Fancy."
(both laughing)
(cheerful music)